joe rogan sits down with sanjay gupta of
cnn and refuses to let sanjay gupta
change the subject he says why did your
network lie
about what the medication i was taking
was they said it was horse dewormer and
joe's like a doctor prescribed it to me
and sanjay goop is like you're right
you're right okay they shouldn't have
said it
that's the power of independent media
and joe rogan may be on spotify or
whatever but that's why they don't like
it that's why they censor it now i
really want to point something out
though in this article from cnn.com dr
sanjay gupta why joe rogan and i sat
down and talked for more than three
hours there are two very important
things that give you insight into the
minds of the cult and boy when i read
you these things will you realize it's a
cult first and foremost he says
i don't think i ever had a conversation
that long with anyone seriously think
about that we sat in a windowless
podcast booth with two sets of
headphones and microphones and a few
feet between us not a single
interruption no cell phones no
distractions no bathroom breaks
um show of hands or actually let's go
will have you ever had a conversation
with someone that was at least three
hours
yeah i mean if you know with breaks in
between but yes like i'd say you know i
mean it's the kind of thing where
convert you know like it's interesting
i have been on the show we've never gone
three hours though we do way more than
that yeah have we have we've gone well
it's two and a half with me
and then when you get here at 7 20
oh
and then we start the show at eight we
end at ten yeah we've definitely talked
okay so we have talked from around three
hours sort of like but even with friends
throughout your life one-on-one yeah no
like conversations before yeah say
you're in a car ride with somebody right
right a long car ride like you'll be
talking with them over the course of a
lengthy period of time yes yes road
trips hold on luke have you had a
conversation oh yeah of course uh lydia
yeah many many many many times yeah 100
especially like the ones they had face
to face going at it for three plus hours
yes i would imagine ian's the one person
was probably the longest conversation
with people out of any of us because
you've seen the kind of guy who's going
to sit there and really just like hang
out with people in a sauna and he was
pre-cell phone
yeah yeah i went to theater school it's
all about communication this is a guy
who is telling you think about that he's
never had a conversation that was three
hours look that maybe it's just me maybe
most people really don't interact with
humans that much i just that's shocking
to me and so i see that i'm like this is
a guy who doesn't actually communicate
with people he sits in a room reads a
book and watches a tv and doesn't talk
to other people but here is you ready
for this one the best part
he says
okay when i told joe early in the
podcast that i didn't agree with his
apparent views on vaccines against covet
i've from acting and many things in
between part of me thought the mma
former taekwondo champion might hurtle
himself across the table and throttle my
neck but instead he smiled and off we
went
yeah that's a weird bias that you have
like here's a guy he is the chief
medical correspondent for cnn the most
trusted name of news who has never had a
conversation with someone that lasted at
least three hours and genuinely feared
joe rogan would physically assault him
in a podcast studio
over his opinions that's what that and
when he could depose him i mean
basically that's what this is and or
he's lying he's just he's lying you know
it's something interesting like people
there's certain people and there's only
a few areas where like it's one thing to
have a conversation with someone over a
long period of time it's another to like
be able to to be interrogated right and
by that i mean like to be asked a
continuous sequence of questions to
examine what you think in your position
on something that happens in law school
right if you're the subject of a
socratic questioning from a professor
that'll happen in debate rounds like
there's cross exam cross examination
that takes a period like there's other
things but there's a lot of people even
if they're very smart and they've gone
through very high level
you know academia or like medical school
or something will have never actually
been in a position where they were
subject to like a sustained line of
questioning about their beliefs and i
think that's sanjay if anything i think
that's probably what he's expressing
this like i was not ready this is like
the first time i've ever been
interrogated like i mean i don't mean to
target like with like law enforcement
but just like questioned about a
position for this length of a period of
time and and he it's the sort of you
know regret kicking in because he got
owned right like he got revealed that he
had to get up and it basically he had to
concede to sound like a reasonable
person that yes in fact cnn had done
wrong here um and then cnn is now so
furious about it that they're putting
him back on the show to like justify
yeah
i i just got i got a request i i would i
would i would um greatly appreciate it
joe if you could just
take some money
drop it in a retainer for some good law
firm and sue cnn
don lemon has come out denied cnn lied
about joe rogan's covet treatment after
claiming the podcaster took horse
dewormer no joke they doubled down on
the fact that multiple hosts lied
joe rogan sat there in front of sanjay
gupta and said doctor prescribed me
medication sanjay said yes they
shouldn't have said that then when
sanjay gupta goes on with don lemon he
does not correct don lemon when don says
no no listen listen it is horse dewormer
don lemon should go on joe rogan don't
be a little whiny you know he never will
of course not he doesn't you know you
couldn't sustain that sanjay gupta is
smarter than just and this is why this
was this is why this was so fascinating
this is why this video went so viral
because this was finally someone a part
of the establishment being sat down and
talked to like a regular human being
without any teleprompters without any
scripts or any agenda and he stuttered
and he messed up and he tried to get
away from the subject and joe was right
on him and he stumbled someone wrote a
very funny comment under this entire
story saying it's it's a very strange
world when an mma commentator stumps a
medical doctor on the topic of medicine
and let's be honest here joe rogan was
absolutely right to call out sanjay
gupta the chief medical advisor of cnn
why he didn't intervene step up or at
least correct the record when cnn was
blatantly lying about him and spreading
dangerous medical disinformation that
would have real life consequences that
probably did have real life consequences
let's just be honest here about this
particular topic sanjay gupta didn't
have an answer didn't he tried to change
the topic he was like yeah maybe not
like i want to talk about this and joke
us no no no no no no let's get to this
issue because this is an important issue
and then sanjay admitted that the main
reason he went on this show was because
he was trying to get joe to get
vaccinated now this is another layer to
this that we need to kind of kind of
unravel here because he admitted i want
joe to get vaccinated that's why i went
on the show that's that's his that's
that's his explanation to all of his
establishment buddies that are like what
the hell did you do you let the mask off
your face you showed us the true reality
of being stumped by him and he's saying
no no i just wanted him to get
vaccinated why the man just went through
covet he has natural immunity there's
many scientific studies and preliminary
findings that are showing that natural
immunity could last a lifetime
still on top of that are you telling him
to get vaccinated it makes absolutely no
point and there have been a number of
complications and a number of medical
professionals saying if you do have
strong antibodies and natural immunity
you might have complications from the
vaccine so again not a medical doctor
not telling people what to do here but
sanjay gupta admittedly came into this
already trying to push bogus
information that that wasn't helpful at
all and and joe rogan just blatantly
called him out on all of his bull crap
and he did not have an answer to it at
all i think i got a lot of respect for
sanji for going on there wanting to go
on there doing it
and just pushing he tweeted it out he
wasn't trying to hide from it and they
talked about like sanjay used to be very
anti-marijuana and then started to
realize when he started to see the
studies he's a books guy he's in the
books all the time when he sees the
evidence he changed his position he
realized that kids that were having like
tremors i remember that a few years ago
this was a long time ago when marijuana
was still a taboo thing where they
weren't talking about the benefits of
thc and cbd he went to amsterdam and
interviewed small children and and
actually i was surprised by his work at
that time so it's very interesting that
you're bringing this up and and you you
do bring up a good point that at least
he did go on and at least we saw the the
mask fall off slip for a little bit but
he's going to get punished he's already
on an apology tour all over cnn saying
yeah you guys were right yeah you guys
were right when in reality no they
weren't they absolutely weren't let's be
honest to to again double down and say
no this was a medicine for horses bull
crap remember when that cnn host
cannibalized uh human yeah that's on
youtube by the way that's fine for you
youtube the cannibal reza aslan yes
right who it's accurate to describe as a
cannibal because it's accurate who went
crazy afterwards he did he did
my own so reza aslan was hosting this
show on on cnn and my understanding is
before the show he was like relatively
normal he was a religious scholar and i
know people who know him like i have i
have friends of mine who know him
and
i i wonder if that that episode where he
ate human brain it was a small piece of
charred human brain
after that it's like he's just insane
the things he posts on twitter like he's
aggravated i wonder if he got like some
kind of shakes from eating human brain
you get like prion diseases man yeah
protein folds yeah yeah yeah yeah and
also the stress of being called a
cannibal over and over he is a
counterfeit was was a cannibal is he
still practicing it doesn't matter if he
was like if you kill once once a
cannibal always a cannibal
no it is though if you choose to kill
someone you're a murderer right well if
you used to be a soccer player and now
you're not you're not still a soccer
player
if if there's ways to like if you're
used to murder and now you don't you're
still considered a murderer exactly but
not a soccer player you are a cannibal
it's like well but to be fair it was a
long time ago so
i think can't to be a cannibal
i got to be honest
i got to be honest if you played soccer
in college and then you stopped playing
i'd still say it's fair to say you're a
soccer you're a soccer player
like you're going to know all about it
you're going to know this you're going
to have retained skills and you'll be
able to pick it up more than anyone else
i would say i was a soccer player if i
don't play at all anymore i was
so i don't that stress of ben being like
you're a cannibal and he's like dude i
did it once and they're like you're okay
that's like you never want to be in that
[ __ ] time
every once in a while dude it's all dude
it's like it's like it's like
with with murder if you choose to kill a
person you're a murderer and it's like
yeah but that was a long time ago and i
only did it one time it's like i don't
care like you're a murderer i just
committed one murder yeah that's just
one just one
and some people do sanjay also made a
very uh interesting point that a lot of
people are talking about right now when
he was on the joe rogan podcast because
he admitted that the aim on the show
when he was talking to joe rogan that
the aim of vaccinating children isn't to
protect them it's to quote slow the
spread and protect adults around them
and if that's the official justification
if that's the official science of what
doctors and cnn and the and the
establishment medical professionals are
standing on they're pretty much putting
young people at risk for the benefit of
the old and if that's happening in the
society that's a clear sign of a
decaying society luke but clearly dr
sanjay gupta is not a smart person but
that's his own words that's i didn't end
saying it not me
no of course of course i'm saying let's
just say this then if that is the
official uh line from sanjay gupta which
is clearly in in uh contradictoring the
the establishment narrative that sanjay
gupta must be a [ __ ] he must just be a
crackpot conspiracy theorist peddling
medical disinformation i i don't know i
mean i think like we were talking about
earlier it's like i have the same
respect for sanjay gupta that i would
have for some novice debater who got
smoked in like a round you're like well
at least you tried you know
like you got beat really bad but you
shouldn't need to have a debate with
with with joe
the problem is that
like it wasn't even a debate joe was
cordial to him he was nicely talking to
him he wasn't he wasn't aggressive oh oh
oh and and in sanjay gupta's article he
says he gifted joe a joe rogan
experience face mask from joe's own
website which joe seemed surprised by
and he makes it seem like joe rogan
who's anti-mask i bought him a mask from
himself and he was shocked and i'm like
he was probably confused as to why you
got him a mask from his own merch store
someone
hey tim i got you something what is it
it's one of your own shirts i'd be like
we have a pile over there yeah
i guess i appreciate it the
self-righteousness and delusion i mean
wow and these are the people preaching
these people never get outside of their
bubbles and this is the first time that
they do and they get smoked as you're
saying that's a good thing so so so this
is you know i mean cnn never has anyone
who doesn't push the narrative in an
agenda never on they never have those
discussions they're they're living in a
world that is tightly controlled the
information that they get is carefully
curated for them and they just know one
particular thing they don't know
anything else so we're talking to
individuals that are literally uh the
hell in colors of our
society he strikes me as highly
intelligent but ignorant in ways and i
can say that from experience because
when i'm on this show i tend to be very
ignorant about what we're talking about
because i don't study and read about it
this is not about it on the spot this
time i'm able to process the information
yeah so the ability to defend your own
position from a hostile interrogator
right or inquisitor is like learned and
it also require if you're not used to it
your car is a lot more work not if
you're on cnn no no not if you're honest
not if you're not if you're um um
mentally capable and i'll give a shout
out to jordan peterson that that
interview he did with jim jeffries where
he says yo should should people be
compelled to use the pronouns and then
peterson's like no you know people
should not be compelled to speak and
then he's like a private business
shouldn't be forced to do this that or
otherwise and then jeffrey says do you
think that the government enforcing
desegregation was a good idea and then
peter went
maybe i was wrong about that
very true
as a mature adult who's in control of
his emotions was just like huh
yeah maybe i'm wrong yeah yeah that's
that's also true that's a very similar
like i'm thinking i guess more along the
ways of getting through something like
that without having to make a concession
that you were wrong right you actually
have to think through it very in very in
great detail and nuance your position my
point is if you're wrong you should just
be like well you know maybe i was wrong
about it look like sanjay knew his job
was on the line like remember when i
told zubi he was wrong when he said
vitamin and i was like it's vitamin
boy
yeah we're wrong sometimes i'm wrong
sometimes too but it's about being able
to admit it that that sets you aside
from the mainstream media that's the
difference they live in a totally smoke
up your
family-friendly show tuckus
world
um
and then we live in a world where we
have to you know go through comments we
actually i mean i'm reading the comments
right now i love you i mean you guys are
interesting to see the ladies yeah if
you see me laughing here it's because of
the comments wait wait thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you